en donnant des conseils des astuces des
méthodes aux parents j'ai constaté les
progrès des enfants
j'ai constaté aussi une amélioration des
relations entre les enfants et les
parents et le parent s'apaiser au moment
du devoir
lorsque j'ai vu tous ces résultats je me
suis dit il faut que j'en parle à
d'autres personnes j'ai commencé à faire
des interviews des des lives des à
donner des conseils et des astuces sur
les réseaux sociaux
mais après vu l'ampleur que ça a pris je
me suis dis qu'il vaut mieux qu'un
maximum de parents sachez connaissez ces
méthodes qui me semblent relativement
simple mais qu'on a toujours besoin d'un
petit rappel alors j'ai voulu mettre un
petit peu tout ça dans un livre pour
permettre un plus grand nombre de
parents d'accompagner leurs enfants dans
leur scolarité mais c'est vraiment un
livre donc que j'ai écrit objectif
réussite scolaire comment aider son
enfant à s'épanouir à l'école voilà je
vis vraiment l'épanouissement de
l'enfant la réussite scolaire et
j'insiste pour dire aux parents qu'il
est vraiment la personne la mieux placée
pour accompagner son enfant dans sa
scolarité dans une salle de classe
nous avons autant d'enfants que de
profils différents
donc autant des dix vie du différend qui
ont chacun une façon d'apprendre et ce
n'est pas évident pour les professeurs
de faire de transmettre en savoir donc
de varier les modalités pour que les
enfants acquièrent ces notions qui sont
dispensés donc vraiment le parent a son
rôle à jouer
lorsqu'à la maison les notions sans losc
à l'école les notions sont apprises à la
maison il faut les réinvestir il faut
réactiver la mémoire il faut suivre il
faut s'intéresser
il faut accorder du temps à l'enfant il
faut l'écouter
mais au-delà de cela il faut mettre en
place
unis
scène de vie j'ai envie de dire pour que
l'enfant soit dans des dispositions pour
pouvoir travailler correctement avant
des résultats visibles donc il faut que
les parents fassent attention au temps
de sommeil à la qualité du sommeil à
l'alimentation
il faut que les parents veillent à
offrir à son enfant bien tendres pour
ses activités physiques parce que
l'enfant droit se dépenser c'est
obligatoire il faut que le parent au
delà de cela fasse très attention au
temps que l'enfant patio les écrans par
exemple mais il faut également qu'il est
la bonne attitude qu'ils soient patients
qu'ils écoutent qu'ils soient l'écoutent
de son enfant qui lui accorde un temps
vraiment dédié également qu'il utilise
les méthodes des méthodes qui fonctionne
donc les méthodes qui fonctionne c'est
quoi des méthodes qui donne envie à
l'enfant d'apprendre c'est quoi c'est
passer par le jeu passait par l'oral
passé parce que l'enfant m6 c'est un
enfant qui apprend beaucoup par le
conduit auditif lui proposer des
musiques lui proposer de mettre en
musique certaines leçons pourquoi pas ou
de s'écouter passer par les couleurs les
images passées par le cor le ressenti
beaucoup pour les kin esthétique
donc c'est le parent qui connaît le
mieux son enfant et qui peut
l'accompagner au mieux dans sa scolarité